um so obviously you and tiger recorded
this together yeah yeah we was we was in
a lab Wayne getting involved where's the
Wayne Uh do you send it out obviously
yes so
um we were just discussing different uh
different features
and my bro AK was like yo
[__] what about Wayne and I was like yo
that's crazy I'm gonna text him because
I was like I just wanted it to feel like
I wanted somebody goaty on it you feel
like me and tiger cool like I want
somebody if we do a third person they
got to be something like like a goat
yeah gotta be a goat and then so I text
Wayne I sent it to him and [__] he sent
it back like four or five days and it
was up from there that's a great
turnaround yeah yeah I think was it
longer than that it's about four or five
days I don't think he like I think he
he's just so he impossible with this
[__] like you can he just I don't even
think he write his lyrics now he just
goes he's one of them guys was this a
swapper did you have to pay Wayne how
does that work man you know this is his
business but it's also love involved you
feel me so he could use you on the
Carter 17 or whatever
I'd be down for sure we're waiting on
the Carter six let's go carter
shout out to Weezy man
um talk about your writing process
though are you writing down are you
going in are you doing the melody first
plugging in lyrics later this I I my
writing process is very race it depends
like if I'm under depression I'm working
with another artist I'm moving however
the energy moves like all right if we're
moving fast we right like we like with
this record we was just going back and
forth online it's back and forth back
and forth like older versions of the
record there's different we're singing
and he's rapping in different places
like it's it's a different but we're
just going back and forth
um with this record but usually I do my
Melodies first like I do I like to do my
melody all the way through it might have
some words here and there for like just
something some spitball [__] but most of
the time I do my Melodies first and then
I go back and then you're going to get
the lyrics oh I might just live with the
melody for a minute let it sit let it
sit down listen right and then let the
concept come I mean the melody is like
really like low-key the most important
part when it comes to a hit record like
you're not humming the lyrics You're
humming the melody you're definitely
humming the melody but well you say hit
you didn't say Thomas records so you're
right no like it's the difference
between a hit and a Timeless record like
I mean like lyrics are very important
but the Melody has to be there otherwise
for sure cannabis would be like the
biggest artist of all time because he's
a lyrical assassin you know what I'm
saying I'm not good what you're saying
the melody is definitely definitely
important for sure but hit I feel like
hits is like you could have a hit that
don't have the greatest lyrics but it's
a hit for right now no it might not be
time we got some of those right now I'm
saying yeah we got some of those what is
this box what's going on here it's just
drugs in there weed oh it's just weed I
see something
so King Palm is uh our sponsor and they
have these giant Leafs
and there's weed inside oh this is an
actual blood yeah wow yeah it's weed
it's crazy shout out to King Palm man
make sure you uh go get you some King
Palm
also while we're doing this we might as
well shout out to Bluetooth
if you ever have any issues with your uh
situation you could use a Bluetooth man
I'm good I know but if you wanted to use
a blue chew yeah maybe you're dealing
with erectile dysfunction you use the
promo code you get a month for free you
know it's crazy maybe you're a little
drunk after the club a little little
whiskey dick it's happening at me at
least that happens to me in the past I
stopped drinking I I stopped drinking
four months ago but yeah it happened
somewhere in the past but it still work
it still work out but it works enough
you just you just gotta have it you know
I'm saying your [__] gotta be filming so
that even when it ain't all the way it's
still doing right well not everyone's
blessed like that you know but
everyone's in at the endowed like you
sir no at the same time it's like
it's like yo I promise you like I I
never
I don't think I ever tried anything to
make me last longer no [__] like that if
you never had a gas station pill or a
honey pack nah bro don't [__] scare me
I'm like what if you take one of them
shits and your [__] is [__] up for
life I've never had one either it's just
like it just looks colorful and they
just look like some shoes I got this
friend though his name is uh silvon
Marshall and uh he always has uh these
Blue Rhino pills everywhere are we
seeing them shits yeah he also kind of
looks like a Blue Rhino oh he's right
there that's so fun yeah crazy huh